This is the sinclair zX81 it's a computer produced by now, sir clive sinclair and launched in 1981 Hence the 81 part of it
It's a really really important machine and one that is hugely misunderstood and unfairly treated in my opinion
This is a machine that I had in 81 as a kid. We got it delivered albeit late as most people and
and
We built it as that kid is quite a simple board just a single board inside
that you sold it together and plug in this whole keyboard mechanism overlay at the front and
You had a computer with the full 1k of memory
what's really important about it is the price so it gets ridiculed because it had a number of drawbacks and
Deficiencies, but nothing else touched you on price, okay?
this was the first machine you could really go out to the high street and buy from somebody like boots or wh Smiths and
That was a big deal, so he's no longer looking in the backs of electronics magazines this was walking down the high Street
Oh look there's a home computer should we buy one and people did they bought a lot of them and that was about the price
so this machine was sub
100 pound to my knowledge about the first machine that actually took that price point
And that made it although, it's still quite a bit of money. You know you had to think about it
Wasn't just sort of throw away money
it was something that people were kind of encouraged to buy the government was talking about computers and how
they were going to be the future and for once the government was right and
And you know everything was about you know moving ahead and getting computers into our lives
And there's x 81 was the cheap way of doing a relatively cheap. We're doing it, so this is the machine
That's what you had when you built it all up it has a very cheap Membrane keyboard, so no moving parts to it
Really you can just touch the buttons there
It has a simple
Circuit board inside just one circuit board with all the components on and it had this connector at the back which allows you to increase
it to a massive 16 k of memory with that ram pack which quite famously it sort of suffered from when ram pack wobble, so
One should plug the the pack in at the back there
If it moved at any point while you were typing your code it would
Lose the connections lose the memory and you'd have to start all over again
and if you typed in C 16 k of code that was
Slightly annoying so you'd have a cassette player most people in their homes at the time had a cassette player?
But they were using for their music, and you could buy programs on those tapes and load them in from tape
So that was feasible you tended to spend ages just getting the volume exactly right?
There would be a pattern on the screen, and that would tell you whether that
Black and white bars and the width of the bars would tell you whether it's about, right?
But even when it was right a half the time it well not half sometimes it failed and you'd have to start again
I
Think we tend to give it a hard time from that point of view I think it works a lot more than we remember you
Just remember those times where it let you down
There was no monitor for it as such you hopefully as a spare TV in the dining room
or kicked you maybe a little black and white screen like this and you'd plug it in to the aerial socket of the TV and
You'd have a power adapter that gives it nine volts, and you plug it in
Screen goes blank for a second and we should end up with a little k in the bottom corner
So that k there is telling us
It's really fractured very minimal booting up time the little delay as we plug the e/m was it testing the memory actually if you did
the same thing without the memory
the K appeared pretty much instantly
So that was just a little memory test that was doing but once you had that you're ready to go, so
You had a look at the manual. It was a very very good menu actually and in the manual
There's all these little example programs that went through basic basic was the language that it used stands for beginners
all-Purpose symbolic instruction code
I've got a feeling that was kind of retrofitted to the word basic round the other way around but anyway and
And most home computers at that time used basic as their as the language, but you've had these little example programs
And you type them in see what they did maybe understand what they did change it for yourself
Make it do something you wanted it to do and for me. That was my first foray into actual programming
typing in the demonstrations
Then modifying them to do what I wanted to do and for most people their first program would be something along these lines
So 10 and they're quite interesting the way you enter the data because you would think there you type in print, Pr int
But actually all you do is press the p key and it has something called a tokenized basic
So it didn't store all these letters. It just stored the one token for the
Print command which allows you to get more programming into a small space
You've got these commands that are written above the keys and that made typing things in that little bit quicker
Before this keyboard that was kind of important
So then I would type in something like Jason
Is great and you press newline to enter it and it would jump up to the top of the screen and that line of code?
Is now in there and the next line?
Probably everybody watching is gonna be practically singing this because everybody knows it
It's like go to 10 so our first line of code says jason is great
20 go to 10, so then line 20 would go back to line 10, and we type him run
or press R for run and press return and
There you go screen full of whatever it was for a lot of people
It would be going into Dickson's of a Saturday morning or wh smiths or boots or whatever?
they'd have one of these on display the method will be somewhat Ruder and
you would type that in press run and leggett and a
Lot of people is there they're fond memories of their first use of computers
But you know as simple as that is we're still teaching that code here in the museum today
to scroll groups that come in and
They love it. You know, it's this media you do that. You type it in and it runs
And they think well actually I wanted to say something else
So they change it, and now they're typing in code and they're making that code their own
And then maybe they get it to count or there are all sorts of things from there
But that's a really good starting point and probably for most people that programmers
That's the first thing they ever typed in it was cheap, and that was the most important thing about it
Yeah, you could afford to buy one of these machine
It didn't have the capacity of the other machines that would come later or even before
And it was you know made cheap in every single way possible, and that was both the beauty of it and also the curse
You know it did take a lot of stick because it wasn't a proper computer
But actually it really was and it did change things for a lot of people
We'd like to thank squarespace for this episode of computerphile the hang on
I know what you're thinking
But they don't just do
Paint-By-numbers websites computer files might want to check out their developer platform and if you enter the code computer file
You'll get 10% off. I put together a website on the squarespace, and I know that as well as looking great
It's also going to be fully configurable
They start at $8 a month and if you sign up for a year they'll give you a free domain name
What's really cool is there's no need for any credit card details to get started just sign up and start building so thanks once again
To squarespace for sponsoring this computerphile video remember enter the code computerphile for 10% off
Is the big reveal?
So this is the internals of our serial number 3 and it's quite drastically different